congratulations on baby number three how
is your sweet boy doing he's doing great
yeah he um came early three weeks early
three weeks early yeah um but he's been
great and you know i think he's
straightforward kids we're still
probably done after this but he's been
great it's been harder to say that
though it's harder to like we're done
because he's been so easy i'm like oh
maybe we could do one more but
you have three kids under five years old
i mean how much sleep are you getting
these days i mean i only had to wake up
once last night so it's not terrible
like i said he's a pretty easy kid so
and our our other two kids are like
totally ours because they like
sleep through the night they no one
deserved like don't talk to them at
night they just
go go to bed at seven eight and they'll
sleep till seven yeah they're like
they're like us they need their sleep
it sounds like i mean y'all hit the
jackpot
i'm really dead yeah
knowing we want to grow our family and
jackson and lyla are getting older
we want to be somewhere that we can see
ourselves a long time now speaking of
lila how are jackson and lila doing with
the new kid on the block
they've been great yeah everything's
been going really well there's not a lot
of drama it's uh we were nervous we were
very nervous especially with jay because
he was not really accepting of lilo when
she was born yeah that first couple days
jackson wasn't too sure yeah but this
has been fake but they both like they
try and pick them up they bring this
binky like lyle is really concerned that
he like has his diaper change yeah
i've been telling everyone this but like
they're very overzealous sometimes
though we have to like
slow down you know like
you can't pick him up you're only two
yeah you cannot change his diet don't
take his diaper off okay whatever you do
gotta love her uh willingness to help
though yeah now how is lila doing does
she realize that she is a middle child
no i don't think she realizes middle
child she's still like i mean she's only
two and a half yeah very just like in
our own world and
it's lila's world and we all just live
in it are there any
differences that you see
maybe with the baby
personalities or anything
i know he's only three weeks old i think
he's like he's pretty easy like he's
definitely more easygoing like jackson
was this baby he's very tolerant like we
allow jax and lila to kind of like
go over him because we know like lilac
when lila was sleeping you don't touch
her if anyone wakes her up you're in
trouble because that just opened up the
whole ring with this kid he's very
tolerant so like
you know it says we allow them to you
know just
dope over him because
if they do wake him up it's cool yeah
tori how was the third go-around for you
this well pregnancy this time was
actually a lot easier than it was with
viola um
the recovery this time was a little wild
it was a little more
intense than the previous two
um
but we're doing good now three weeks
postpartum we're both like
getting it all figured out
my dad's starting point was not 30 acres
15 and he cuts off the forest which is
our favorite part
um
the whole thing was weird like
all of a sudden it's like he makes
excuses and reasons why we're not good
enough to run the farm there's been some
family farm drama that's playing out on
social media in the midst of of you guys
trying to
you know enjoy this moment with your
family growing first and foremost how
are you guys doing we're we're good yeah
we're up here we're enjoying our new
spot um the family farm drama happened a
while ago it's been played but now
on the show but then yeah unfortunately
it was brought to social media
but i think i said my piece and that's
that and um
you know the farm is going to sell
you know or be sold apparently but we
are up here and
[Music]
yeah we have a nice spot up here we had
a school for jackson we found a church
we making friends so
we're pretty excited about just starting
our new our new
life up here
a new chapter is there a world though
where there like could be a joint sale
no no i think no i think um
not just i'm not the only sibling
involved here
but it's it's i think i think it's i
think we found our spot like we found
where we're supposed to be and we're
content and we're happy it would have
been nice but it's not our call and
there's nothing we can do about it
so you know you got to move on
and do what's best for your and yeah
a lot of fans have been
offering messages of of hope for
you and and your dad to kind of put this
behind you do you think that'll be able
to happen or are you two communicating
yeah like yeah we're family um you know
we had a discussion since that all
happened on social media and
i think it should have never been put on
social media to begin with
and now we've moved on
i think this is a good opportunity to
move forward as grandfather
dad and son yeah not and there's no more
business associate if we can't
clearly we can't conduct ourselves
like separate those two
so you know maybe this will finally help
you know hey you are grandpa right
nothing else and um there's no other
ties and then we'll go from there
between you and your siblings and
everyone having babies
when the family is growing is that a
window for healing to
kind of occur in your family and bring
everyone closer together
yeah yeah no it's totally babies and
birthdays and everything
create opportunities to bring everyone
together
um
like a lot of hurt feelings have
happened over everyone like
you know we're not
innocent in all this either but it's um
it is what it is it's not our call
um
i you know the whole family
was
you know built the equity of that place
you know and built uh
built it to what it is you know but it's
it's not any of our calls but you know
my dad's and
you know that's his call which is fine
you know i wish it would maybe was
played out a little bit more honest
leading up to it like we're talking year
two four three four five years ago but
it you know it didn't and it's fine but
again
yeah we have a baby i have my own family
to focus on we don't like people ask me
are you sad i'm like
okay i'm a dad three kids and a husband
i'm not crying over my childhood house
being sold but yeah i do wish if it was
gonna get sold it was done
in a better way but it wasn't which is
fine
but we've moved on and now we're up here
and we're excited what are you guys
dreaming up over there yeah like i this
this property is pretty wild um like
besides the house it's not really
landscaped or anything so we want to do
a lot of projects here on the property
build a barn and
you know get stuff for the kids a
clubhouse got a chicken coop you'll see
that in upcoming season already multiple
projects have been built
um
so do a lot of that and um yeah just get
our kids involved in that next stage of
life they're coming out of those toddler
years and jackson will probably be doing
sports and
just school
activities yeah so just entering that
stage of life like what do we want him
to you know what opportunities do we
want to give our kids jackson and lila
music or sports or hobbies we'll see
this in the show he has his leg surgery
and he everyone you know he you know
painful he has you know pain medicine
and just all these things and learning
to walk again and i was like no no the
hardest thing this whole thing is is
weaning him off all the attention you
know he got just an overdose of
attention for like two three weeks and
just weaning him off of that was
honestly the hardest
hardest thing of it all
though
isn't it crazy to see to see two i mean
we saw your journey the cameras follow
you into the hospital now we're seeing
the cameras following your son into the
hospital is that
emotional for you does that make you
think too of like this full circle of oh
wow we have been on on tv for a very
long time
yeah nobody yeah jackson's surgery and
my leg surgery was on camera yeah it has
been a long time i i guess i didn't
think of it until you just said it right
there that yeah my legs sounds a little
older i guess
a lot more intense yeah mine was pretty
intense um
but yeah i didn't think of but yeah we
have been on tv for a long time yeah now
does jackson
is he ready for full-time school with
kindergarten is he ready to be away from
mom and dad for the whole day
i'm not sure if he's ready or something
no
i'm not sure he's ready to be away from
us but he's ready for school he's like
stoked on school yeah he's very much he
wants to learn he's really eager to like
read and write and yes he's very much in
he's in soccer class sunday school he's
he's very much into the classroom
setting and friends and he's very
confident in himself like he doesn't he
he doesn't lack confidence and he
doesn't lack the curiosity and the
bravery i think sometimes that kids like
you have to encourage them like it's
gonna be okay like he's like it's gonna
be okay it's you know i'm excited for
this and what was it like a month into
school he
we park and we walk him into the school
then he sees like second and third
fourth graders walking themselves into
school so then he goes mom
he told me i couldn't get out of the car
yeah mom you're not allowed to get a car
yeah he's walking himself yeah i would
have never i would have never i ever at
preschool walk myself into school
that confidence again he's setting
himself up for his own show
oh my goodness how would you guys say
that the dynamic if it has changed
now that there are three babes under the
roof honestly going from what would you
say in the last
going from what to what it was going
from one to two was way harder from two
to three yes like two to three was like
honestly i said it in a on social media
like it's like josiah's been here this
whole time yeah you know it's like
nothing changed it is you're just kind
of adding like you're not just adding
like you're adding cards to the train
now
you know
it
it he's just part of the program
especially when you have a kid that's
literally like
like just so chill it just makes it
easier like
it just makes every transition and
jackson and lyla are such an age they're
buddies they're just together they're
they're it's jackson and lyla and then
we have josiah so it's not like it's not
like it's three different kids it's it's
it's jackson's very much loves being the
older brother lila follows him to the
ends of the earth and
it's so that side of things is handled
and and then yeah we have josiah here
[Music]